hoy quiero platicarles del capitalismo
las mujeres y las cebras
y el hilo conductor que une estos tres
elementos es el dinero
el dinero surge como la evolución del
trueque cuando el trueque deja de ser
eficiente para nosotros partimos de
intercambiar bienes como el ganado
granos
pasamos por los metales llegando a la
moneda y al billete y todo esto por la
necesidad que teníamos de unificar lo
que significaba valor para nosotros
los sistemas económicos como el
capitalismo se enfocan en administrar y
maximizar el dinero y organizarnos a
todos nosotros alrededor del
pero yo creo que el capitalismo está
incompleto
y ha fallado en tres principales cosas
la primera es
pone el interés propio por encima del
propósito 2 ha dado un valor exorbitante
al dinero y la tercera es ha olvidado a
la mujer
mi primer contacto con el dinero fue a
los cinco años cuando en un libro de la
escuela me adelanté y bien las páginas
del último un dibujo que me gustó era un
perro mucho más lindo del que está aquí
y se los prometo y decidí calcar lo
colorearlo y empezarlo a vender y mis
amigos lo compraron y yo aprendí dos
cosas la primera era me tenía que apurar
para vender lo máximo que pudiera antes
de que en la clase llegáramos de esa
página vieran el perro y el interés de
ellos por comprar mis dibujos
disminuyera y la segunda era que si yo
tenía la habilidad de detectar una
oportunidad le sumaba esfuerzo podía
tener una ganancia en este caso dinero y
en eso se basa la economía en
interpretar estas transacciones que
generan ganancias de momentos de
oportunidad de momentos de necesidad o
de deseo
y si queremos entender la base de la
economía tendríamos que podernos
responder esta pregunta que es cómo
llegamos a tener nuestra comida sobre la
mesa
nosotros producimos un porcentaje muy
pequeño de lo que consumimos el resto lo
compramos y entonces respondido esta
pregunta se hace de la siguiente manera
son las transacciones que pasan en el
intermedio o sea el agricultor tiene que
cosechar el trigo que el panadero compra
para transformar el pan que en la tienda
compra para poder venderlos a nosotros
o al menos eso fue lo que respondió este
amigo él es adam smith el padre de la
economía moderna y lo que él decía es
que todas estas transacciones se basan
en el interés propio o sea que el
panadero no hace el mejor pan por ser
buena onda o porque te quiere hacer el
bien sino porque si él no hace el mejor
pan no lo va a vender y él no va a
obtener un beneficio
todo según él y según su tesis se rige a
través del interés propio pero olvidó un
elemento importante adam smith nunca se
casó vivió la mayor parte de su vida con
su madre
y precisamente cuando él se preguntaba
cómo llega la comida a mi mesa ella su
madre fue lo que adam smith pasó por
alto
todos los días la mamá de adam smith le
servía la cena por la única razón de que
lo amaba y esa variable fue la que nunca
adam smith contempló en ninguna ecuación
económica
el trabajo de las mujeres no ha sido
contabilizado en el tiempo y hoy en día
sigue sin estar contabilizado aún cuando
las mujeres ya somos parte del sistema
yo inicié mi etapa laboral en the board
que es una aceleradora de negocios y me
acuerdo que de repente me di cuenta que
no había mujeres
de un portafolio de 100 emprendedores a
nivel nacional sólo tres de ellos eran
mujeres me llamó la atención porque
además yo
casualmente formaba en mis equipos en
mayoría mujeres o inclusive en muchos de
los casos en su totalidad de mujeres y
los mentores y emprendedores de
endeavour menciona cómo es eso de
trabajar con pura vida a ese un acoso
hormonal rarísima que han de llorar un
día sí otro también
como las controlas
me llama la atención me puse a
investigar y los datos están ahí a pesar
de que en méxico somos el 51% de la
población las mujeres sólo representamos
el 38 por ciento de la población
económicamente activa y peor aún de
todos los emprendimientos formales sólo
el 19 por ciento son dirigidos por
mujeres
méxico se está perdiendo de talento así
que yo decidí en 2012 fundar victoria
147 justamente para reunir a la mujer e
incluirla en el sistema pero hoy 6 años
después me he dado cuenta que no
queremos las mujeres incluir no
solamente en el sistema queremos
cambiarlo
y a qué me refiero el ecosistema
emprendedor hoy está obsesionado por el
dinero
se enfocan en crecer más ganar más valer
más dejando a un lado el propósito o la
razón por la cual decidiste iniciar tu
proyecto
hoy el dinero no es un medio se ha
convertido en un fin todo este
ecosistema nos empuja al consumismo a
acumular a esta ambición desmedida de
tener olvidando lo que quiere decir el
valor marginal que pasa no tiene el
mismo valor el primer y único par de
zapatos que tienes que el segundo que el
tercero que el cuarto al mismo tiempo
estarán de acuerdo que el hombre más
rico del mundo no puede estar en sus dos
yates al mismo tiempo
en este ecosistema los inversionistas
las aceleradoras las universidades están
bien enfocadas en encontrar a los
próximos unicornios los unicornios son
estas compañías que llegan a tener
evaluaciones de miles de millones de
dólares
pero qué pasa con aquellas empresas que
no tienen estas características o que no
les interesa tener esta aspiración
en estos seis años que llevo trabajando
con mujeres y nos voy conociendo más me
doy cuenta que emprendemos distinto que
los hombres y ojo no estoy hablando de
generalidades estoy hablando de una
tendencia
la tendencia dice que las mujeres
en nuestro principal driver no es el
dinero no quiere decir que no nos guste
no quiere decir que nuestras empresas no
lo generen pero en nuestra ecuación de
prioridades no sólo está el dinero están
también nuestras prioridades personales
está el balance está el bienestar y
hemos creado ecosistemas y sistemas que
funcionan a nuestro alrededor que son
mucho más flexibles mucho más humanos y
menos esquizofrénicos
en victoria 147 el 85% de las
emprendedoras que llegan con nosotros
empezó su negocio con un impacto con una
razón de impacto social no
necesariamente con la razón de ganar
dinero
ahora a todo esto que tienen que ver las
cebras
hace un par de años leyes sobre el
movimiento de las cebras y las cebras
son estas empresas que se distinguen por
buscar un propósito que basan su sentido
en un beneficio no nada más para los
accionistas sino para todo lo que se
derrama alrededor
y sobre todo son empresas que fomentan
la colaboración fomentan el crecimiento
sostenible no el crecimiento obsesivo
sin quitar la vista el ser rentables
las cebras al multiplicar se genera en
cambio los unicornios conservan su
situación de monopolio yo cuando observo
mi portafolio de mujeres veo que muchas
de ellas tienen estas similitudes de ser
cebras
y yo creo que hay muchísimo valor en no
enfocarnos nada más a aquellas que están
obsesionadas en este crecimiento
obsesivo sino que realmente están
generando un valor a lo largo del tiempo
y son sostenibles y que sobre todo están
proponiendo el ecosistema algo mucho más
humano mucho más flexible
y hace en los últimos dos años he tenido
dos contrataciones de mujeres estando
embarazadas
he tenido todos los comentarios que se
pueden imaginar empezando por el de
ellas en donde me acuerdo perfectamente
con eugenia que llegaba de 8 meses y le
dije oye pues me parece es un perfil muy
interesante y te quiero contratar está
segura ya no me has visto y te estás
escuchando qué necesitas para que esto
funcione pero me he dado cuenta que el
sistema de negocios como hoy lo tenemos
no está diseñado para integrar a la
mujer e integrar a nosotros como
personas parece que entramos a la puerta
de la empresa y se nos cae lo humano
y la última contratación que tuve con
belén también que está embarazada de
linz de hecho no le dio su comprobante
de maternidad porque ya estaba
embarazada cuando yo la contraté
claramente hay muchas cosas en el juego
que tenemos que cambiar
quisiera que hiciéramos una reflexión
si mañana que no estemos ya en este
mundo volteamos para atrás y veremos
nuestra vida como una película
qué les gustaría ver
les va a dar un poco de contexto la
esperanza de vida en mexico en promedio
son 68 años de los cuales si juntamos
todos los minutos horas días que
destinamos a ciertas actividades una
vida promedio se ve más o menos así
pasamos 23 años dormidos
diez años trabajando
pasamos cinco años transportando nos
tres años haciendo filas y trámites
un año y medio buscando cosas esas
llaves que se te pierden todos los días
incrementa el promedio
si siendo parte de este sistema
ustedes creen que aporta a como quieren
ver que termine esta película
yo creo que estamos a tiempo de mover
las fichas y cambiar las reglas
y yo lo que quiero fomentar es que
integremos cada vez más a gente que
piense distinto que integremos cada vez
más este sistema a las mujeres que
tenemos una propuesta de cambiar y hacer
este sistema mucho más humano y con
mucho mayor propósito muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]